smell
we know when it's good and we know when
it's bad
but there's a woman in scotland i'm a
joy moon who can smell the unsmellable
my nose went on fire joy milne is the
only known person who can smell
parkinson's disease
i have an extremely sensitive sense of
smell
i can smell it mainly on the forehead
and the back of the neck to joy it has a
greasy musky odor it is just a heavy
smell to me she first noticed it on her
late husband les milne 12 years before
he was diagnosed i just thought he was
tired and he wasn't showing enough it
wasn't very welcome of course me saying
to him well you're smelling
it wasn't until she attended a
conference with other parkinson's
patients that she realized the smell was
something more
when i walked into the room i thought
gosh these other people smell the same
as liars does at the end of the meeting
i stood up and said why were they not
investigating the smell of parkinson's
no one was investigating because no one
else could smell it researchers set up a
controlled experiment to test joy's nose
she was asked to distinguish a set of
t-shirts worn by those with and without
the disease
she insisted one of the subjects in the
control group had the musky scent
the man rang about eight months later
and said i've got parkinson's so i had
pre-diagnosed somebody
by the time most people are diagnosed 80
to 90 percent of the damage is done
so joy's mission is to help scientists
improve early detection methods if they
can find these people earlier it would
stop this anguish
that would make such a difference
you